ses voeux ou 2018 il s'adresse d'abord à
vous à vous qui avez pris quelques
minutes pour les partager
il s'adresse au ventre à vos proches à
votre famille à ce que vous aimez et ce
sont des voeux très simple les mêmes que
l'on redit chaque année pour que
s'éloigne les chagrins et que au
contraire se multiplient les moments
heureux et les moments de succès bonne
année d'abord à vous puis bonne année
vous comprendrez que ce chapitre passe
en premier bonne année pour la ville de
pau que j'ai lancé chance d'administrer
c'est une ville qui est en pleine
métamorphose ceux qui la visitent tous
ceux qui vivent le savent bien
en sortent de terre des réalisations
inédites originale avec un réaménagement
du centre ville avec la création d'un
magnifique jardin en plein centre-ville
de deux kilomètres de long qui s'appelle
le ravin du et das et puis aussi avec
les nouvelles halles
et puis aussi avec le stade qui a été
inaugurée autant de visages nouveaux
pour naviguer mais pour moi le plus
important de tous ce n'est pas les
bâtiments ce ne sont pas les bâtiments
ce n'est pas lui organismes le plus
important de tous et les femmes et les
hommes qui forment cette ville qui
partage sa vie et il ya une chose qui me
frappe depuis longtemps c'est que nous
vivons dans un temps dans un siècle où
l'ennemi public numéro 1 c'est la
solitude et nous voulons faire de notre
ville
la ville anti solitude par excellence
alors nous allons mettre en place un
grand plan pour que cet ennemi public et
la solitude reculer peut au contraire le
la rencontre la solidarité le
compagnonnage ait droit de cité dans
cette ville devait aussi pour notre
agglomération toute nouvelle
trente et une communes 165 mille
personnes l'agglomération pau béarn
pyrénées dans lequel un magnifique
travail est en train de se faire et je
veux dire ma gratitude à tous les
ennemis qui ont laissé de côté leurs
singularités pour former une équipe au
service de cette communauté
d'agglomération et le même mouvement va
se poursuivre en 2018 puisqu'un en 2018
le béa tout entier va se réunir pour
porter son avenir et son image toutes
les communautés de communes et
d'agglomération pour former un pôle
métropolitain
c'est le domaine juridique et qui sera
le pays de béarn qui va trouver ainsi la
force et la puissance de construire son
avenir
et puis ce sont des voeux bien entendu
pour notre pays
ce sont des voeux pour la france est le
premier de ses voeux c'est que se
profilent en 2018 l'élan du printemps
cet élan qui est née de l'élection de
manuel macron à la présidence de la
république qui nous a offert une chance
unique sans précédent c'est que un pays
qui semblait décourager depuis des
années et des années a retrouvé son
optimisme a retrouvé le goût de vivre
le goût en tout cas d' affronter tous
les défis qui se présentent à lui c'est
une formidable chance il faut qu'elle se
renforce en 2018 deuxième voeu pour la
france c'est que ceux qui en ont la
charge
d'abord les citoyens parce que dans une
démocratie la responsabilité première n
appartient aux citoyens
et puis ceux qui la gouvernent tour du
président de la république du
gouvernement de la majorité dans
laquelle mouvement démocrate tient toute
sa place cela saisi ce que il faut mener
de front le travail pour l'efficacité on
est en train de faire des pas importants
pour la santé économique du pays
et le travail pour la justice efficacité
et justice
c'est exactement cela le signe
distinctif du nouveau projet que la
france est en train de construire et
cette deuxième voeu que je fais pour lui
que je forme pour le pays troisième veut
que notre vie publique s'installe dans
ce nouveau climat que 2010 est à provo
et pour cela il faut que les
institutions change pour que nous
apprenions à vivre et à travailler
ensemble même s'il y rentreront des
nuances des différences parfois même des
confrontations
cette compréhension mutuelle c'est le
fruit que nous devons attendre du
changement de nos institutions
et puis quatrième veut il va de soi nous
savons tous que rien ne peut se faire si
l'europe ne se forme pas ne se construit
pas parce qu'aucun des défis qui sont
ceux de la planète ne peut être relevée
autrement vu le développement durable ni
la protection de l'environnement ni les
très grands changements qui tiennent aux
technologies de l'information
ni les problèmes de fiscalité d'évasion
fiscale
tout cela ne peut se traiter que si
l'europe est forte pour ça il faut une
voix et ce doit être la voix de la
france est la responsabilité
particulière de la france de penser
l'europe nouvelles et de données à cette
nouvelle inspiration la volonté qui lui
permettra de se faire c'est le quatrième
veut que je forme à ce voeu est rattaché
le fait que si l'europe existe eh bien
ça signifiera qu'il y aura un nouvel
équilibre dans le monde un monde qui est
aujourd'hui tellement déstabilisé
tellement dangereux on a l'impression
que chaque pas est risquée en raison des
incertitudes ou des foucades de grands
dirigeants de la planète
en tout cas l'europe est un élément de
stabilité et il faut la construire
tout cela au fond se résume en un voeu
peu
la promesse que porte en elle la france
promesses à l'égard de ses citoyens et
promesses à l'égard du monde
cette promesse devienne ou redevienne ce
qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être
une raison de vivre pour chacun d'entre
nous
très bonne année 2010 8